when you look at Robert Whittaker  obviously you know staple the  middleweight division uh you know former  world champion is there things you look  at there and you feel like you have the  advantage over Whitaker I have a lot of  advantages one of the things that  excites me I don't know why but I mean  it is cool I'm gonna I'm gonna be  breaking into pounds per pound but yeah  stylistically man like  he's a karate guy like he's really like  he's really bouncy and I think the three  rounds actually favors him a little bit  but just uh just about me to make  another adjustment really that should be  a five rounds five hundred percent at  your guys level yeah especially where  you rank this should be a five round  five I think so yes  [Music]  like a magic trick